le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
ce n'est pas une découverte la Réunion
possède un climat qui rend les terres
très fertiles
la réunion a aussi la particularité de
posséder une grande variété d'espèces
végétales endémiques
beaucoup de ces espèces se trouvent au
sein de Terra protégés appelés ens pour
espace naturel sensible propriété du
Conseil Général
afin de protéger au mieux ces espèces il
n'était pas possible de cultiver dans
ces terres
alors que des agriculteurs qualifiés
sont sans travail faute de terrain des
parcelles de terre ne sont pas
exploitées quelle solution existe pour
remédier à cette situation les
agriculteurs et les ENS peuvent-ils se
rejoindre pour le bien de tous on en
parle maintenant dans le lien social
Christian est issu d'une famille
d'agriculteurs qui exercait en métropole
travailler la terre il connaît pourtant
Christian est sans activité
professionnelle depuis un bon moment
ses compétences et sa qualification sont
indiscutables
il y a deux ans il a même validé ses
compétences en obtenant son BPA Brevet
Professionnel Agricole
mais Christian n'a hérité d'aucune terre
et il n'a pas les moyens dans louer et
encore moins d'en acheter d'un côté un
professionnel sans terre et de l'autre
des terres non cultivées il ne manque
plus qu'un élan de solidarité pour que
Christian puisse réaliser son rêve
cultiver des produits ici à la Réunion
j'ai toujours vécu auprès de mes parents
qui étaient déjà agriculteur en
métropole et
ben je retourne aux sources quoi puisque
bon plusieurs années j'ai pratiqué un
peu le bonsaï des choses qui sont
proches de la nature
et
pour moi l'agriculture bio c'est je
pense que c'est l'avenir et il y a
beaucoup de clients qui qui fait la
demande de manger proprement sans
pesticides ni engrais chimique pour moi
ce serait la pente comment dire me
retourner encore à l'inscription au
chômage et
ne pas avoir d'activité quoi et bon ben
c'est ça
ce terrain là c'est une opportunité pour
moi d'avoir
en fait un activité un peu de fruits
et puis de commencer
à travailler à cultiver
à restaurer les terrains qui sont
inculte actuellement et cela va me
permettre de m'insérer dans une vie
active
mon but c'est de faire du maraîchage bio
un peu d'horticulture
de
production de miel voilà
conscient que certains agriculteurs
passionnés ne peuvent cultiver faute de
moyens financiers le Conseil général
permet d'exploiter des parcelles
d'espaces naturels sensibles
bien sûr c'est par celle de terre
doivent continuer à être préservés ainsi
que les espèces endémiques le porteur de
projet est autorisé à exploiter ces
terres mais s'engage à respecter la
richesse et la fragilité
environnementale du site
le Conseil général a le devoir de
veiller au respect de ces parcelles et
par conséquent du patrimoine réunionnais
la location de ces terres est bon marché
pour permettre une accession plus facile
une idée forte qui permet de créer de
nouveaux emplois de développer
l'agriculture biologique l'apiculture la
vanille et bien d'autres produits tout
en prenant soin du patrimoine naturel
le dispositif d'inscription et de
demande de dossier est en cours de
finalisation mais d'ores et déjà on peut
dire qu'il faudra répondre à certains
critères simples pour faire la demande
comme nous l'explique Nassima dadar la
présidente du conseil général il faut
juste avoir une carte avec ça et donc
être reconnu agriculteur ou bien
apiculteur et vouloir s'installer ne pas
avoir de terre et donc il suffit après
de faire la demande au Conseil Général
pour que vous puissiez avoir à un prix
très modeste la possibilité de vous
installer sur un espace naturel sensible
que vous soyez homme agriculteur ou
femme agricultrice en offrant la
possibilité aux agriculteurs de
s'installer sur des espaces naturels
sensibles nous faisons de
l'économiquement efficace mais aussi du
socialement ce qui n'ont pas d'argent
pour s'acheter des terrains du
socialement équitable et puis de
l'écologie durable
économiquement efficace socialement
équitable écologiquement durable les
trois piliers du développement durable
deviennent ainsi une réalité très
concrète via cette idée innovante en
louant à bas prix ces espaces naturels
sensibles à des agriculteurs le Conseil
Général remet en route tout un secteur
de l'économie agricole la culture bio
l'apiculture et la vanille sont entre
autres des activités et des produits en
pleine croissance un potentiel local ou
comme la vanille pour l'exportation
d'un côté il y avait des terres de
qualité non cultivées et de l'autre des
agriculteurs qui ont besoin de terre
pour travailler il suffisait d'avoir
l'idée de réunir les deux pour lancer
l'agriculture réunionnaise sur une
nouvelle voie plein d'avenir et porteuse
d'emploi
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais